machinist or inertia a bit charitable
this is the extraordinary story of one
man's dream to save the most overfished
see in the world if any good night then
begin everything everything is good
neither shonda me to success is a
synthetic are not sapphic izakaya has
almost single-handedly turned a ravaged
bay and turkey into one of the most
effective and thriving marine
conservation areas in the Mediterranean
it is like a heaven for me right now
there's so much fish underwater now and
there's so much life his hope is to
inspire others to bring marine life back
to one of the most famous but damaged
parts of the ocean we need to establish
more no fishing zones even in
Mediterranean the center of civilization
it's a chilly December morning on
turkeys eastern Mediterranean coast and
sapphic ezel kaya is a man on a mission
right now we are in the article no
fishing zone he's dedicated to enforcing
the no fishing zones that he has helped
create here in Bukavu Bay this is the
most major spawning and nursery area so
that's why we have to keep this area
safe from all kinds of fishing pressure
so mature professional any kind within
just 20 minutes
Safa and one of his Rangers have spotted
something suspicious pardon but
consulates become Restless they panic
United Mickey level in vicinity
good idea Shawn the me to 6 si the
souvenir Akana
Shaunda air Bananarama - sorry gonna
keep leaning try to pray people radiance
is a bacchanal understandable done it's
all about the enforcement you know our
Rangers are day and night just going for
any kind of report that there is an
illegal fishing activity exists you see
he is living
since marine conservation is Safa set up
the Ranger system here in partnership
with the Turkish authorities they've
seen a significant drop in illegal
fishing it all began after Safa first
visited Bokova Bay in 2008 on a research
trip from his home city of Istanbul the
damage he witnessed to marine life
compelled him to stay and devote his
life to repairing this I saw that this
place is just there is nothing
underwater it's like a big nuclear war
happened and everything has died no fish
no invertebrate no more kranji I said
this couldn't be worse than that and
this was a kind of opportunity for me as
a kind of sign you know zephyr lobbied
his government to make the Bay a
protected area and ten years on his
research suggests marine life is
increased by 800% within his no fishing
zones but the revival faced another
threat new species of fish coming into
the Mediterranean through the Suez Canal
these invaders were eating the native
fishes food and grazing parts of the
seabed bare so Sokka had to adapt and
come up with an innovative solution
invasive species we cannot get rid of we
have to learn how to limit them the
easiest way is just to consume them
to make this work he had to hook the
local population into eating these
unfamiliar fish and that meant
persuading people to change their diets
people don't know how to cook them so we
prepared recipes and we printed them on
the brochures
then we organized a big festival zappers
vision has delivered the bonus of
raising the incomes of local Fisher
people by 400% and bringing a previously
decimated industry back to life
visit the fishing cooperative here and
you'll find an array of invasive species
for sale caught outside the no fishing
zones so Conda Dimas you see two letters
in the air Ellen locum balloons cuckoo a
lecture on the island Istanbul
shaundalyn a day when I'm no today the
article started Zaffis innovations have
delivered for both people and planet in
this small way and he's now working to
create another marine protected area in
Turkey it looks like a lonely mission
latest figures showed just 0.04 percent
of the Mediterranean is a no fishing
zone 50 times lower than the average for
the whole ocean
Safa is going to need all the help he
can get we need to improve in to
establish more no fishing zones but the
more important thing we should bring the
enforcement right immediately as soon as
we establish them
[Music]